We've looked at a lot of different blending nodes that we have available inside the AnimGraph.
And now we're going to take a look at state machines.
Now this is where you can set up all of this animation logic, but in more of a modular
fashion, where you can sort of compartmentalize what your character's animations look like
in each state, and then define the rules to transition from one state to another, essentially
determining when you can transition from something like your running state into your
jumping state, and then into your landing and falling states, or anything really that
you want your character to do.
Now the reason we build this into a state machine is because if we were to directly
use the AnimGraph for all of this logic, instead of making use of these modular building blocks
of a state machine, you'd end up with a lot of nodes and you'd probably find it quite
difficult to keep track of what's going on.
So back into the engine, I've unhooked the animation blending tests that we were kind
of experimenting with before for our zombie walk, and hooked back up the logic that already
existed for our character in this third person template.
And I'm just going to open up the state machine here, our main state state machine.
So this is an example of a fairly simple state machine where we have a character who can
idle, they can run around, and they can jump.
Just to understand sort of what's going on here and what these different states are doing,
I'm going to hit play inside the level and show us transitioning between the different
states.
So if I hit play, just make sure that our third person character is set as our preview instance.
Strike this out of the way a little bit so we can see the character moving.
You can see as we're moving around, we're in the locomotion state.
But as soon as I jump, you can see that we transition between all the different states
that we have set up for the jump.
So as we jump, we go into the jump state, and then as we're coming back down, we enter
the fall loop, and then as we hit the ground, we're going into that land animation.
When that finishes, it transitions back to the locomotion state.
When you're setting up a state machine, you'll always have an entry node here at the start,
which is typically used to define the default state of your character.
So in most common cases with a locomotion setup, that's going to be like your character's
idle state.
You then drag off this and choose add state, or you could right click and add state and
rename that to whatever you like, whatever the state is.
And then you can connect it up.
And if you double click this, this is where you'd set up all of your animation logic for
this state.
So typically, these tend to be quite straightforward.
You would just drag an animation in and connect it up and hit compile.
And you'll see that that animation just plays because that's our entry or our default state.
Now these can get a bit more complex.
For example, you can apply additive animations inside here to the current pose that the character's
in.
So with this example, it looks like the landing animation would play on top of whatever animation
locomotion pose we're currently in.
If I reconnect those up and just delete this.
But as you can see, these can get quite complex.
Now once you've created all the different states for your characters, you'll want to
determine when your character is allowed to transition into these different states.
And you do that by setting up some transition rules, which are these white icons here.
Now the main purpose of these transition rules really is to output like a true or a false
response.
So if I open this up, this is where you would set up the logic to say, okay, what information
is going to allow me to transition into this state?
In this example, when we're transitioning from the falling to the jump state, we're
saying, okay, are we falling?
If we are, and our velocity in the Z axis is greater than 100, then yes, you can enter
that will allow us to enter the jump state.
Now when you have one of these transition rules selected inside the details panel here,
you get a preview of what that logic might look like.
So it's useful to just have that and not have to double click each time.
As you can see as well, when you hover over, you also get a bit of a preview of that.
You also have access to the blend settings here where you can control, you know, the
duration of the blend into this state and how that blend might be calculated using different
curves.
And oops, you can even add your own custom curves to that as well.
So if you wanted to get into the jump a little quicker, for example, you could change this
to 0.95 maybe, and then change how the animation blend is calculated and just get that looking
how you want.
So a state machine is essentially a collection of many animation graphs containing the logic
of what your character should look like in those different states, as well as a place
to determine the rules that allow your character to transition into these different states.